hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday November
27th
2022 what's 23 sorry
23 I've been [__] that up all
year I mean Jesus Christ by the time I
realized it's 23 it's going to be
24 that's going to be a great Boston
year oh my God can you believe it's 2020
FAA do you know there's people in
Massachusetts they say
FAA f
u-w ah
fo how old your niece oh my God she's
already FAA you want to get a
pizzer
um oh why do I always do that you know
cuz I miss it back there but I will tell
you I absolutely love Los Angeles
especially this time of year when it
gets cold out and the Sana
winds come blowing in from across the
desert blowing
out all the homeless vets that you
cheered at a football game and then they
lived under a bridge too close to your
[__]
house and you called your local
politician and said get him the [__] out
of here
but they never talk about the back end
of the military career you know after
the NFL charges them for a commercial
and we all like thank you for your
service and all that [__] when they're
homeless where are
we
huh driving by huh with your [__]
Yeti hanging out the window cuz you your
your personal trainer told you to drink
more water
to flush the [__] Botox out of your
ass that you had
bleached is that what we're doing out
here um yes we are but it's also it's a
great time of
year it's a great time of year to be out
here
um you know my tour is done and uh I
went to the C show today you know what's
funny the NFL the amount of games the
NFL had spread out this week again
really [__] pissed me off it just
really [__] pissed me off okay
football's for Sunday you got Monday
night now now we got [__] Thursday
and you're trying to take Frid
Friday sorry I got the hiccups I just
had some leftover um
Thanksgiving for the let's see Friday
Saturday Sunday third day in a row and
then I throw it out
Monday my wife's [__] hovering over
me going I don't know that was made on
like Thursday I'm like it's Thursday
it's it's fine it's fine all right stop
hovering over this
masterpiece all right I got the mashed
potatoes right next to the stuffing
mashed potatoes go on top of the
stuffing gravy goes over the top cuz
they both take it well next to it is I
have the Cranberries the Cranberries are
in between the turkey and the side
dishes okay mac and cheese is on the
other side of the stuffing and the gravy
then you got your greens coming around
to meet the [__] turkey and then you
got your piece of bread or whatever the
[__] you want in the middle okay I have
a system this isn't my first [__]
Rodeo okay
um anyway uh yeah the [__] NFL it's
like what are you doing to me you're
going to have three [__] games on
Thursday you can have one on
Friday you're going to have the rest of
the games on Sunday and then one more on
Monday it's like I'd like to see my kids
grow up can you put the crack pipe down
for a [__] day and in between that in
between that we had call college
football the biggest games of the
regular
season this weekend I mean Jesus Christ
I'm lucky I still know my [__] name
now the old me the old Billy old Billy
Whiskers right the younger
me Billy Whiskers I like that the young
I'm on one I'm [__] on one four days
of Thanksgiving feeling good um they ow
me I would have [__] sat there and
you know barely paid attention to
relatives and I would have [__] sat
through three [__] games [__] you NFL
I'm not [__] watching three football
games on
Thanksgiving Jesus [__] Christ give
me one good [__] game I don't need to
watch I'm not you're taking my whole
[__] day you
[__] trying to take my whole [__]
week you know what they are the NF in
the [__] NBA they're like that
[__] woman that wants all your time
and can't accept the fact that you got
friends that you want to hang out with
one night on the
weekend you're hanging out with your
friends tomorrow night but we scheduled
a double header on Friday yeah [__] you
[__] I'm not watching it I'm not
missing my kids growing up because
you're going to [__] you got 32
[__] teams and you're going to spread
them all
out
right like one of those mentally ill
Geniuses you know they can't [__]
hold down a
job but they can do the math you know
that figures out how to do something I
don't know I'm too stupid to do the
right they're a beautiful
mind at least that's what Hollywood
taught
me there's people out there that are
special and they have beautiful
minds and Hollywood loves to make movies
about them you know Beautiful Minds that
play posan that figure out phys physics
that [__] count matches in [__]
Las Vegas they've been doing it
forever it's it's a Well warn it's it's
literally a
genre you know to make you stop and
think the Hollywood wants you to stop
and think about how you treat people
with special needs while they're out
here in their infinity pools with barely
legal women with [__] blow and and
and whatever AI technology
who the [__] are you to make a movie
that I'm supposed to learn something
from huh why don't you watch your own
[__] movies H you ever think of doing
that um one of my favorite things in the
world the Hollywood lecture Oh by all
means
Hollywood Sports integrated 70 [__]
years ago Hollywood still looks like
baseball in like
um every award season someone's going to
go up there and give the every all the
other states a
lecture
um anyway uh yeah so I just decided
today like I watched a football game on
Thanksgiving I watched the second half
of the
Lions and the uh the Bears and then I
watched the
Dolphins was it Jets game whatever
whatever the [__] they I can't even keep
track of it it's too much for me all
right
and then on
Sat I watched uh Hail To the victor
valant Hail to the [__] big heroes hail
hail to Michigan [__] you oh higho
State um I watched the Michigan uh
Wolverines um win the game I would not
say that they they kicked their ass they
did not I would say I was very impressed
with the quarterback of Ohio State and I
was underwhelmed with the
corners uh on Michigan man I know they
had a couple of picks you know one was
the end when he had a force to make a
play so you know that's a mulligan they
had one [__] pick but out you know
dropped another one and Jesus Christ how
many [__] times did they get burned
deep in that game that was a little uh a
little unsettling so I'm happy but I am
happy they bits three years in a row all
right nothing to [__] brag about Ohio
State beat us seven times in a [__]
row so you know and I've been so busy
this year I didn't even realize LSU was
having a great [__] year and their
quarterback's like a Heisman Trophy
winner you know why that is you know why
that is guys I guess maybe I'm working
too much maybe I'm trying to be too
involved as a father you know people do
that oh you you know you're excited
about oh did you check out [__] no I was
at a soup kitchen ladling out broth for
homeless people no jeez
sorry okay you know even Jesus got a
hooker on one day right can can I
[__] can I go see fast in the
Furious part 12 aren't I allowed to do
that what about my Thanksgiving so
anyway I watched that game and I watched
the [__] Alabama Auburn game and I'm
telling you right now there is an
Unwritten [__] rule like back in the
day if the Canadians were
down uh back in the day when they were
just oh my God it's the [__]
Canadians right that that they just had
to go on the power play the the official
crew on a home game in the Forum was
required to put the Canadians on the
power play to give them a chance to tie
it
up that's the kind of poll they had now
I'm not saying Alabama did any sort of
[__] we all know that that happens in
the springtime right when they when they
run around the South with bags of
cocaine [__] and [__] T-top
Corvettes trying to get their [__]
recruits we all know
that okay there's no reason for Sabin to
still have a fanny pack we know what's
in it um no there's like this Unwritten
[__] rule
that Alabama cannot have two
losses like watching teams try to give
Alabama their second loss of the year
you know what that's like that was like
me trying to beat up my older brother
the amount of times I had him beat but
Psych logically he just had it over me
and I would still [__] lose and then
I would think afterwards like why didn't
I keep [__]
going I should have brought the house
instead I rushed
to Jesus [__]
Christ they [__] stop him with three
and a half minutes to go they're [__]
what are they up by 10 are they up by
seven or
whatever they kick the ball back to him
the [__] kid gives a fair catch falls
on his ass and drops pops the ball and
gives Alabama the ball back now I'm not
saying that if he didn't do that they
would have won the [__] game who
knows they could have gone three and out
only burned off you know [__] 40
seconds off the clock Alabama could have
got it back and by so anyways they drive
down the [__] field they get a
touchdown all right now Auburn's only up
by three they get the [__] ball
back you know they get a couple of F I
don't know what the [__] happened it's
just
all going together with Michigan's final
drive keep getting the first downs and
running the ball down their throats like
[__] the Big 10 football is they
[__] get they ended up giving the
ball back to Al to
Alabama it's third and goal they take
like a 20 yard [__] sack they're all
the way back to like the 35 yard line or
something final play of the game what do
they do they rush
to the guy's just standing back there
for like a half a minute
long enough for the cops to trace a
[__] phone call and then he finds
this kid in the back of the [__] End
Zone I just bursted out laughing going
like you just can't do it it's illegal
although I will tell you who going give
sh God damn Georgia
Bulldogs that's going to be a [__]
game that is going to be a [__] game
I oh wait a minute are they not in that
game are they in that game I don't know
how it works they sort of split the
thing up
like who goes to the [__]
championship game is Alabama out in are
they the SEC
West I I can't I can't keep [__]
track of it anymore so anyway so I did
that on Saturday so on Sunday what am I
going to do now am I going to [__] oh
and by the way I've been watching a
bunch of episodes of Cojack which my son
loves and my daughter doesn't like it
she doesn't like shows where people go
to sleep and then they go to heaven
that's her way I saying dying so I'm
like all right I I get that but my
son he he loves it you know this cars
this [__] good-look women you
know his guns and [__] he just he loves
it I'll tell you this I got to get the
name of the actress on
uh
season season 5 episode
one absolute
stunner uh she plays an undercover cop
or whatever I told you this [__] dude
she do a scene she [__] she's
like uh she's a dancer and a model so
she's got this gorgeous body sick ass
dress that she's
wearing she comes out of the elevator
she walks by two Porsches and then gets
into a
silver uh Ferrari
Denali you know there's some gun play
too in the middle of that and there's a
[__] AMC Pacer and then next to that
is like a [__] yellow station wagon I
sent the clip to Dean Del re goes dude
did you see the chopper in the
background I missed that like cojak the
[__] cars a just Second To None So
I've been watching all that so today I
decided you know I'd go to the car show
and bring my daughter um I miss it every
year and it was something the last time
I went to the car show if you can
believe it was like [__] 1982 or
um we used to go to some sort of
Convention Center you know I remember we
used try to talk my dad into buying like
a van this is when like this is how long
ago like when custom Vans were out this
things were [__] sick right they had
like you know it's a iCal van but then
they they Vans were always just like
just [__] on the inside it was for like
working people it was right when they
started to make was the beginning I
would say the van was sort of the first
luxury SUV is when people started
hooking up vans so the regular hot rod
people started doing it
themselves and then
um these [__] creeps right they
[__] you know they had like two
bucket seats and like a water bed in the
back and then they would have like
[__] carpet going from the floor up
the walls in the ceiling and all that
lava lamp and all of that [__] back
there you know or so the legend goes so
then after a while you know these things
become cool and then the big three
decide to start making them and I
remember they had like this [__] like
a
Chevy a Chevy one before they had that
Space Age looking front end in the late
80s it was sort of the square body front
end and uh it had like I think the had
the two chairs up front four Captain's
chairs which was just the ultimate in
luxury I think the interior was Vore
which we like oh my God it's so plush
and fancy and then the back away in the
back was like a bench seat and we beg my
dad to buy
that he said you know think about like
come
[Laughter]
on why can't you just do this this would
be [__]
awesome why do we always got to get a
sensible car this doesn't make any sense
that's why it's [__]
awesome you know one of the best things
to buy is is when you're looking at
buying something and then the person
next to you is going I mean what what
are you going to do with that I mean
that right there you know you're buying
some [__] cool
[__] you got room for that don't you
already have one of those all of those
questions you know what that means in
the United States of America buy
it oh just once just once can you buy
the custom van so we can go to church
with [__] Smiles on her face while
everyone looks at you like you're
dealing
Coke
um I get why my dad didn't buy that
[__] thing I get
it oh man that thing was [__] sick
and then Toyota had one Volkswagen had
one you know we were pushing hard for
the vans that year and I remember the
last year I went to a car show this is
how long ago it was the Pontiac Fiero
came out and we were all like oh my
God it's so sporty right remember when
they used to call cars sporty do you
know when that came out right around the
catalytic converter when all of a sudden
an oldmobile cutless 442 had [__] 190
horsepower couldn't get out of its own
[__] way right but it still had the
442 uh I guess four grand the first four
stood for four
grand four
tires and two jerk offs is all you could
put in it or it can't go up a hill I
think that's what 442 started to mean as
opposed to I think it used to mean four
barrel four-speed py rear end there sort
of a debate about that um and as much as
I'm a Ford guy as much as I like the
Lincoln Continentals in the late' 40s
and that one from Entourage I mean
Entourage kind of made it a little bit
of a hacky car because it was such a hit
show and then then every like started
looking at it like it was the Entourage
car it's like no this is the car JFK got
his [__] whacked
in okay that's what this is
okay um this was a pimp
car back in the day pimps drove these
[__] things gangsters drove these
[__] things um haven't said that I
love that car and I thought it was the
perfect car for [__] onour Russia um
and I gotta be honest with you one of
the last shows with a cool car when I
was growing up every
show you know the guy you know the lead
had to have a cool [__] car and he
had to have his own [__] car he
couldn't have a car that was already on
another series you had to have your own
unique car that said something like you
knew who the [__] character was by
the car that he pulled up in those days
are gone because every car is gray white
black I don't know occasionally there's
a [__] red I feel like colors are
starting to come back so anyway I go to
the we go to the car
show and um it was funny man like uh
Porsche wasn't there BMW Audi all the
[__] high-end German [__] wasn't
there Jaguar wasn't there it's just this
[__] internet's just killing this
[__] like they used Mercedes none of
that [__] was there but they had all the
Fords and you know I'm a Ford guy I
[__] love the Fords you know they had
all these this [__] Ford merch it's
like why can't you just have the Ford
logo I don't need Ford built Ford tough
I don't need Ford Lightning just that
blue and white
[__] logo with the oval thing around
it can't can't you just do that is that
asking too much um anyway so we we go in
there and uh couple it things they had
that were [__] wild they're going to
have a baby Raptor so you know you got
the Raptor right now they have the Ford
Ranger is that a [__] Ford Ranger
they got the Ford Ranger
Raptor and then they had the Ford Bronco
Raptor and I was I was there with my
daughter and Dean Del re and there was
this one that was just this sick [__]
color was sort of a gold and brown but
they put all these weird stickers on it
and [__] and Dean was going I'd buy this
and just put heat to those stickers and
take him off and no one notice a raptor
until they looked at the [__] hood
scoop and I was like that's a [__]
cool idea so they had that they had a
Mustang that was a six-speed standard
transmission then they had this sick one
that was a Mustang GTD I want to say 300
grand and I'm sitting there going like
you're going to find some [__] jerk
off to pay 300 grand for a Mustang you
can buy a [__] Ford GT for that you
can buy a Ferrari for that what is this
thing doing he's like it's a th000
horsepower it's all carbon fiber and all
blah blah it was basically a track
car um I don't know how many that they
going to make but out of all of those
you know I'm not the biggest mustang guy
I was when I was younger but I like the
uh what is it is it the I always I
always get it confused is it the Ford
falcon or is it the Ford
uh uh
Fairline it's the same Mustang chassis
it's the one the guy from uh Fast and
Loud had um that he raced the mechanic
put the black hood on it and they forgot
to [__] Bolt it down and it went
flying over it that car I like that one
um but I will tell you I'm I'm a sucker
for anything that's still standard
transmission I hate the [__] paddles
but but anyways we checked those out
those were cool um and then there's this
new kind of car that my wife had
actually ridden in when she had a gig um
in Miami I think and it was uh what's it
called Lucid their high-end one things
are [__] sick and they're all
electric so they're fast as [__] and it
has
like the range is like 518 miles
and they have a super fast charger all
of that [__] like there's a lot of like
you know what's amazing is is the amount
of [__] misinformation about electric
cars there's a video on [__]
Instagram with the guy like going this
is the solution gas com look at that
every charge is full and look at this
line of electric cars these people can't
go home there like 20 [__] cars it's
like where the [__] is that when the
[__] does that ever happen the [__] out
of here here's the real deal you [__]
buy a Tesla they give you a home charger
and you just plug it in like your phone
at night that's it and then you're good
for the day good you're good for the day
unless you're [__] driving I don't
know to
Albuquerque then yeah you got to [__]
pull over who gives a [__] you're still
not paying for gas the whole [__] way
it's it's
free yeah it takes a little bit longer
it's not going to be like that it's just
going to get it's going to go faster and
faster and this [__] [__] about
electric cars cuz I love a gas
combustion engine I can't get myself to
buy an electric car I like them I ride
drive my wife's car it's just not it's
it's
I I I like hearing the engine I just
like hearing it like hearing the sound
of you
know the
[__] the thing doing the job I just I
like that right the electric one the
speed is [__]
amazing you know they don't leave any
stains in the driveway there's no grease
no nothing no nothing no dripping no
nothing right I don't mind I you know
it's just not for me but I wouldn't sit
there and be like you [__] stupid
[__] electric cars like and then also
acting like there were no electric cars
until now it's like when they first
started making cars there were electric
cars they got to stop [__] saying
that these [__] idiots don't know
what they're talking about the thing and
they're sitting there nitpicking they're
making these videos where they're
pushing down on the dashboard of the
Tesla and it's making all of these
haunted house sounds
and it's like they're just throwing
those sound effects in
there because what else are they going
to say about
it it can well no matter how fast your
thousand horsepower thing is you're not
going to be faster than a [__]
electric car so now they're just
nitpicking like your ex-girlfriend when
you're showing up with another Hardy you
know she doesn't look good in that dress
that like that's what the [__] gas what
kills me is no one's saying you can't
have a gas combustion
car nobody's saying that [__] that's it
all right you'll be fine and I think
whatever car you have will be grand even
if they all of a sudden just said like
you have to because of the [__]
global warming you got to do this [__] I
think if you have like a a a a gas
combustion car especially a
classic they're not going to [__] with
you you'll be grandfathered
in like you know they didn't just tell
everybody in the NHL to wear a helmet it
was like after this year you have to
[__] wear a helmet that's how it went
you know I don't know I think there'll
still be a certain percentage of gas
combustion cars on the on the road like
I that's never going to go away it's too
much
aart and a really cool part of of uh
what makes this country awesome is
people [__] working on their cars and
trying to figure out a way to make it a
little faster a little [__] cooler a
little little lower a little higher all
of that [__] so I don't think it's going
anywhere so but if if you're sitting
there like and you don't know [__] about
electric cars do not believe any of this
crap that they're saying about the they
just turn on and then they blow up and
they burn down a house it's all [__]
it's it's that's coming from oil
companies and and and and people that
don't sell [__] electric cars but
they're here they're going to be here
they're fast as
[__] sort of boring to look at the
Porsche one's cool I'll tell you that
that [__] check out that
um that um Lucid one like the high-end
coup man looked
[__] badass it it it definitely
looked like a man's car and it had a
nice front end that's my big thing with
a lot of electric cars I don't like the
front ends but like this one was cool it
had wraparound light that look [__]
cool like you were in Blade Runner or
some [__] um and I don't know why you'd
have a problem with something that could
have four [__] people in it and a
trunk full of [__] groceries front
and back and still beat a Corvette off
the line I me that's [__] wild it's
kind of The Best of Both Worlds you get
to buy the dad car and you still get to
go fast maybe kill your whole family you
know I'm kind of concerned about that
new Tesla that goes 150 mph it's a
[__]
missile and and like the amount of
people that just suck at
driving I mean that could that could be
uh I don't know why does it go 150 mil
an hour
[Laughter]
anyway so uh I saw the Ford Lightning I
finally got to sit in that truck that
thing was cool um the frunk where the
engine was is a whole another area where
you can just put [__] which is [__]
unreal and then in there listen to this
[__] they had four three-pronged outlets
and then these like two or three of
those little ones for like iPads and
your phone and [__] it's [__]
unbelievable um and they're saying that
the truck if you lose you can actually
use it as a generator to [__] put the
lights on in your house for a couple two
three days that's a pretty good truck
right I mean I know it doesn't make the
noise and everything
listen I'm not like all I'm saying here
is stop hating on electric cars all
right stop buying this [__] that
they these pieces of [__] that [__]
burn down your house they don't all
right that's just people who don't like
change or they're going to lose money if
these things stick they're here to stick
and if you like a gas combustion engine
just [__] buy that you know like what
is the [__]
problem um I kind of like them both but
like uh I gotta be honest with
you I definitely like the the old school
[__] so um when we went
downstairs uh there was this whole
custom area and that's where it had all
like the uh the low riders and that
whole sh all of that [__] and the
[__] bikes and all of that um
that whole all that whole Latino culture
and the the [__] sick ass detail on
the paint motorcycles I saw this Harley
that was detailed so ridiculously and as
I was like videoing it it was sort of
across the room I was looking at this
helmet and I was like is that like a
motorcycle helmet that looks like a
Dodgers baseball
hat and I went up and that's what it was
and uh I did take a picture of it but
the way they had the bikes and
everything lit up it really [__] with
your phone so it doesn't look good it
was like that thing alone just the
helmet and the amount of time and effort
that was taken on
that was a work of art and like the
level that Mexicans go when they paint a
[__] car I mean they detail the
firewall under the hood under the trunk
they don't [__] around it's
unbelievable and some of them it's like
they got so many layers of paint you
feel like you could put a hand like it
looks like
water um so my daughter was loving all
of that stuff and and the bicycles and
all of that and then some you know you
know the classic ones that they that you
always see low riders like uh
Impala um and then interestingly enough
like those Town Cars from the early
90s um that was cool they had the trunks
open and they had the whole that whole
system in the back that makes it go up
and down which I don't even understand
that was all [__] cool and then we
went up and I went to the dark side I
went to the Chevy area and I was like I
don't want to go in here as a Ford guy
what if I like the [__] Silverado or
whatever but uh I checked out their
trucks they look cool I like the colors
of some of them but I'm just I don't
know there's something about the
interiors and the front grills I'm just
not into them but I I will say I love
the square body
Chevys and I like the early 60s ones
where that that generation that sixth
generation of the Ford F100 I'm not into
I like the Seventh Generation I like the
55 Ford I like a 1940 Ford is this just
going to be a [__] car podcast I
think it is
um anyway so we we did that let me uh
let me do some reads here oh Jesus half
a [__] hour on that [__] um I haven't
even got no wait I haven't even gotten
into what the [__] I wanted to talk
about
so
um what did I just do here go back to
that record recing still recording all
right so I
um have been smoking cigars and drinking
coffee like a [__] fiend like a like
like I'm running a newspaper I feel like
that's what they used to do like come on
you got to make the deadline and another
cup of coffee and they're just smoking
since the end of July and I was doing
this great thing where I was like taking
the first 10 days off of
everything so none of my my vices would
get out of control but then what
happened was in
June you know me and my wife's birthdays
are in the first two weeks so I was like
well you
know let's just take I I'll do the 10
days at the end of the month which of
course I didn't do and then July came I
started to do it and then it was July
4th weekend and then I didn't do
that then August we were on vacation the
first couple weeks of August September I
was in Europe and then October I'm on a
bus trip and I just [__] somewhere in
the end of July I just took the hand my
hands off the wheel of my life as far as
my vices which is basically cigars and
coffee and um I've been trying to stop
but like I feel like my touring schedule
and getting ready to promote old dads
and all of that I just had a lot on my
mind and I just couldn't kind of stop
the merry-go round
so thanks given night my daughter came
and she went to sit next to me right
after I smoked a cigar and she made a
face and usually she goes oh my god dad
stop smoking cigars and she didn't she
just made the face and then didn't say
anything and I was like I don't like
that she's used to me smelling like a
[__] ashtray so I was like [__] this
I'm not smoking
cigars uh got to take a break right so
then the next morning I woke
up and we had a friend over family
friend uh one of Nia's friends and I
made her a cappuccino and I was going to
make myself one I was like you know what
why do I just not have coffee today I
know I'm going to get a little bit of a
headache let me just [__] shut that
down too and just just for today all
right I'm not saying I'm not drinking
coffee just not going to do it today I
know the headache's coming let's just
see how bad the headache is let's just
see how addicted to caffeine I am oh my
god dude around 1:00 it started C coming
on and it was fine but then by 3:00 it
was like what the what is this right and
from 3: to about I don't know
5:30 6 o' I had a pounding [__]
headache and I was just sitting there
like just laying on the couch like wow
how much [__] coffee have I been
drinking that like 24 hours without it
this is what's
happening so you know I made up my mind
I'm stubborn [__] so I just plowed
through it Nia's hilarious she's going
like what's the matter what's the matter
and I'm like I I'm not drinking coffee
today I got a splitting headache she's
like well go have a cup of
coffee why would you do that to yourself
you
know and um I'm like no I just I just
got to do this I need to like I need to
like you know I gotta [__] I gotta
get off the [__] merry go around here
for a second got to see where I'm at so
and she goes well at least drink a bunch
of water so I started doing that and I
started feeling better and uh it was
amazing right you know it sucked that
day but the next day I woke up you know
I felt
good and I had no desire to drink coffee
so I said [__] it I'm not drinking
coffee I'm certainly not smoking a cigar
and then I woke up today Sunday I said
yeah you know I'm not [__] doing this
[__] and you know what all of a sudden
now I'm like you know what I want to get
back into
reading want to get back into studying
French you know I haven't stretched in a
minute I need to go to the gym like I
need to take care of myself like what
the [__] was I doing I was on that like
for those of you in the music business
or whatever you do where you tour you
know when you just sort of get into that
uh you know it's like that fetal
position where you're just you're out
there
surviving you know and you got your
little vices that kind of get you
through like let me just okay okay what
do I got to do all right do they got C
let me just get a cup of coffee if I
just get a cup of coffee okay or they
they got an area where you can smoke a
cigar and it's like fine so I let the
whole thing just really get out of
control but um fortunately I'm not like
a full-on [__] addict I am a habit
guy so I am
able in moments of like you know seeing
my daughter making a face and not
pulling away and I I that registers with
me I go I don't like that and I'm able
to say [__] this and but then I don't
have to get a sponsor and go to meetings
or anything like that I'm somewhere you
know let's say it's a
speedometer you know when the car can go
120 M hour as far as my addictive [__]
I'm about an 80 I'm going about 80 85
I'm definitely getting a speeding
ticket
so you know I had the splitting
headache on Friday on
Saturday I woke up and I was like you
know I feel like I need the foam roller
and I need to stretch all those airplane
and bus Smiles off of me here let's turn
this around flexibility was for
[__] and um but I definitely felt better
played a little bit of drums and then I
went uh and then this morning I woke up
and I felt good you know I stretched
right when I woke
up and uh made the kids breakfast as I
always do and I knew I was going to the
car show I said [__] this I'm going to
the gym so I just did like a half hour
on elliptical just get the blood flowing
and uh and now I'm back
and I'm [__] reading again I've been
reading uh Reggie Watts wrote an
autobiography about growing up in Great
Falls and you know his whole journey to
become one of the most I don't know just
one of the most interesting people I've
ever seen on stage so I've been reading
that and uh still watching Cojack and
[__] but like you know I got to have
something right but I sort of redefined
my back porch that was a place where I
just had a [__] Espress so and a
cigar and I kept saying to myself like
what do you want to do Bill you want to
get better at smoking cigars and
drinking coffee you want to get better
at French you could be playing drums
right now and all of this [__] so
anyway um that's where the [__] I'm at
so uh I'm going to try to uh I don't
know like know like how long I'm going
to
go this
time but
um I mean I gotten it down to like two
cups of coffee a day I'd have a
cappuccino in the morning and then in
the afternoon sorry to Italian people
listening I know I'm not supposed to
have dairy after 11 in your world
um but uh I couldn't believe it so I was
kind of like I need to like that that
[__] that needs to [__] simmer down
there that was not a healthy
relationship if I have that level of a
[__] headache so
um and then cigars have always been I I
just need to go about five days
five days I don't give a [__] like as
far as like not doing it right now like
Friday and Saturday were easy today's
the first
day I was kind of like well what am I
going to do now I came back from the car
show I usually at this point go out on
the back porch and I lo I loved it you
know I'd smoke a cigar and I always you
know call my friends back East get
caught up and [__] and
uh I was just like well you know what
you can do instead of wasting all that
time [__]
you know hurting yourself with your
vices why don't you go record your
podcast and knock it out there while
your son takes a nap so that's what I'm
doing so anyway ohill you know I'm just
going to try to like take care of myself
a little bit
more
um in this next year that's that is what
I would like to do and uh speaking of
taking care you oh would you look who it
is it's stamps.com
everybody you know did you forget to ask
stamps.com to your holiday wish list
last year we all make mistakes
stamps.com has been helping businesses
Like Yours save time and money during
the holiday rush for 25 years with easy
access to USPS and UPS services and
premium rates for all your postage needs
the holidays are hard enough make things
easier than ever with stamps.com you've
heard me talk about stamps.com they've
been sponsoring the show for over 9
years now and if you haven't tried it
what the [__] are you waiting for with
stamps.com all you need is a computer
and a printer they even send you a free
scale so you'll have everything you need
to get started now taking care of orders
on the go is even easier with stamps.com
mobile app if you need a package pickup
you can easily schedule it through your
stamps.com dashboard and if you sell
products online don't worry stamps.com
seamlessly connects with every major
Marketplace and shopping cart running
low order shipping and mailing supplies
labels and even printers from the supply
store get huge carrier discounts up to
84 84% off USPS and U UPS rates to help
your bottom line plus stamps.com
automatically tells
you uh your cheapest and fastest
shipping op option for 25 years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over 1 million businesses get access to
the USPS and UPS Services you need right
from your computer anytime day or night
no lines no traffic no waiting give your
business the gift of stamps.com so your
mailing and shipping is covered this
holiday season sign up with the promo
code Burr for a special offer that
includes a 4-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and enter bur
buur R I got a buddy of
mine from back in my uh junior high and
high school days uh
uh tells me you know he gives me the
heads up his his his call every week
gambling is the Iowa Hawkeyes
under I was hanging with them in Vegas
the over under was 27 and a half and it
came
in so he texts me before Saturday he
goes look at the O look at the under for
the Iowa over under it was 25 a half it
was the lowest under in college football
history I
believe and uh it came in I think the
final score was
13-10 Iowa over the Nebraska Corn
Huskers I mean that's just [__]
unbelievable so there you go do with do
with that information what you will all
right now here we go um oh look at this
email this is about the movie
Leo which has been killing my kids love
it when when Leo gets gets all started
goes what
[__] whatever that thing Sandler does
which just [__]
hilarious um
Turtle yeah I play Squirtle and turtle
uh hey Billy shell shock great job as
the turtle would love for them to leak
your sound booth out takes keep trucking
go [__] yourself they actually um I
think Netflix put out a quick one on the
day that I actually got in the booth
with Adam which was uh
which was awesome and difficult trying
not to laugh cuz he's [__] hilarious
he is effortlessly effortlessly funny
and uh had a good time with him Robert
Smigel and everybody over there so um
I've gotten so much positive feedback
over that I mean I've had having a nice
little run here old dad's did
great Leo's doing great the club soda
keny you guys keep watching that club
soda Kenny and you keep sharing it it
gets enough views someone's going to put
some some money behind it and you can
see a movie starring club soda Kenny I
mean tell me the world doesn't need
that I think they
do um and I when we had the best [__]
time shooting that thing we had such a
good time I have a good time on
everything that I do CU I I always I I
work with I work you know don't believe
all this [__] that you hear about
electric cars and don't believe all this
[__] you hear about Hollywood people
there's a lot of [__] cool ass people
out here that are fun to work with and
I've been lucky enough to uh pretty much
you know I've only worked with a couple
of [__] other than that everybody else
has been
aces all right
shampoos Oh no you're going to ask me
about shampoos Jesus Christ what do I
know about
those huh maybe for my undercarriage
geez uh shampoos Bill I've been reading
about chemicals and products that do the
opposite of what they're they're
supposed to do there are books on this
that stem less from a conspiratorial
angle and more from the designed
obsolescence phenomenon of the last 50
to 60 years well look no further than
[__] apple apple sabotages their own
products in the history of
like design obsolescence I don't think
the technology ever existed where the
company you bought a product from
could then from a distance [__] that
product over so you'd have to come back
and buy another one uh shampoos have
sulfates parabens chlorides and a host
of other chemicals some have a purpose
okay let's say you want to lessen the
grease in your naturally greasy hair you
would use sulfates sulfates are used as
engine
decreasers uh it Bay Aid in this one
area is you supposed to say may it may
Aid in this one area okay but ultimately
CZ causes you to lose or thin your hair
out as they say in the medical community
there is no free lunch Johnson and
Johnson and other companies own both the
shampoo conditioner products that cause
these things and also the hair treatment
products as
well suspect yet effective business plan
guys this is this is why I'm telling you
blue ties and red ties they're not
watching any of these people can you
imagine going out there and deliberately
making somebody go [__] bald wait a
minute what shampoo did I use um maybe
you shouldn't have spent so many nights
all there it is washing your hair in the
70s ah [__] um well I didn't actually I
I we grew up we didn't have a lot of
[__] [__] you know we had a period
there where we were struggling so my
mother used to wash our hair like once a
week once a week you'd stick your head
in the kitchen
sink so you get those [__] Nails
going you'd be like covering your eyes
because so the soap would go in your
eyes it would hurt back then before they
[__] practiced on all those rabbits
um
yeah that's how it was that was how it
was in the 70s hand me- down clothes
wash your hair once a week you went out
side you [__] ran
around a stick was a gun it's a simpler
[__]
time and you know what a cleaner Planet
maybe I don't know probably not with the
bad emissions back then uh diet dear
Billy Dixie
Chick about a week ago you asked the
advice on what diet actually works I
found out at March that I have type 2
diabetes it shocked me I was 5' 10 and
only 305
lbs uh anyway I was eating like a dick
for years plus it runs in the family I
should have paid more attention to it
more than I did well type two is
reversible isn't it I believe that's
reversible so uh my mother has it as
well but was able to manage it by eating
more protein still she still uses
medication though to lower her blood
sugars I started to to research what I
could do and I came across Dr David
Unwin a GP I guess general practitioner
practitioner in England he had a few
webinars on using a keto diet to control
type 2 diabetes without any medication
my doctor didn't prescribe me any
medication initially either to gauge
where I was at when I first was
monitoring my diet anyway I went full
keto apart from a from a serving of
vegetables every day for lunch it was
basically carnivore after 3 months my
HBA A1 the measurement of sugar attached
to red blood cells which was 9.2 was now
down to 5.7 which is 0.1 above non
diabetic levels blood pressure pressure
and cholesterol has dropped to all to
within normal levels oh and I lost 50
lbs wow good for you man keep going I'm
still not taking any medication
and in fact the doctor hasn't asked me
back in again in about 6 months now I
can eat a little bit of carbs now too
because it
works because how it works is removing
fat around your organs which puts
pressure on them making them not work
properly still watching the diet and
blood sugars though honestly reading
about it and other people's success
stories with it I thought it too good to
be true but it worked for me just
thought I'd send you this before you get
cancelled
good luck and go [__] yourself
um why would I get cancelled I like I
always said my career is is the
punishment anybody who gets cancelled
inevitably tries their hand at doing
standup on the [__] road uh which was
you know wasn't offensive it was just
more sad to me like wait a minute I
thought I was I'm I'm the Bottom
Rung Oh I thought I was doing well all
right underr
everybody reading the the instructions
and Living
Lean uh hey Billy I finally started
reading instructions in my 30s yeah I
know it just takes so much [__]
patience but it's
never it always goes better it always
goes better you know when you're
assembling something you should read the
whole [__] thing and then go back
because there's always one thing make
sure that you did this or that'll [__]
this Step Up
if you just start assembling it you know
it always goes wrong all right
underrated reading instructions and
Living Lean hey Bill I finally started
reading instructions in my 30s that
that's you're like a prodigy it only
took you to your 30s to do that took me
to my 50s it's amazing what knowing how
something works can do for your life I
even watched a few videos on the iPhone
capabilities no one knows exists that
are useful I've also taken your advice
and stop
taking on more junk I've thinned the
herd of material possessions and I'm on
my way to being a three guitar one
skateboard laptop
phone uh 10 of my favorite books and
clothes for the seasons I can move
anywhere in one car trip I feel
Invincible dude that's that's amazing
man like if I could go back and talk to
my younger self the amount of
[__] that I that I'm just looking around
my office
now and I'll tell you what's funny is if
you start doing well in life people ask
you if you want stuff and you say no and
they still send it to you and then you
got to like try to how do I get rid of
this I don't have room for this I had a
buddy of mine asked me he goes hey man
they got this new Brewing zip up dude
you want it I said no dude I have too
much Brewing [__] I just did Comics come
home they gave me more Bruin stuff I got
two broin [__] he was all right cool and
he [__] sent it to me
anyway and this is the best part it's
the wrong size so I don't feel guilty
cuz I I saw it I was like all right he
gave it to me he gave me a nice card I
go I got to wear it I got to wear it
plus I love wearing sports [__] because
Nia hates my sports [__] she goes you're
too old to be wearing that stuff you
look like a [__] gym coach it's just
like you know well what what the [__] do
you got
on huh Cruella Deville the [__] out of
here you going to sit there keep you
know dressing all fancy I can dress like
a
[__] a [__] [__]
uh gym coach oh my God I thought the
[__] M on my refrigerator came off
that was really going to annoy me um
anyway I
uh yeah I have so much [__] [__] I
got a little travel guitar I have not
used that [__] thing in
Forever you know I got this little
[__] flight simulator xplane 11 thing
anybody going for their instrument
rating you want this [__] thing you
can have it I'll [__] ship it to you
free of
charge reach out to Andrew
thus um you who wants a travel guitar
there we
go just getting those couple of things
out of here I got all of these books I'm
getting rid of these books cuz I'm never
going to [__] read them again there's
just a few that I love that I'm going to
keep and then I'll have a place to put
my records cuz my records are on the
floor why did I buy all these [__]
records what am I a DJ AM my quest love
do I have a [__] gig I got to do no I
don't and I got my little high five
[__] radio killer [__] thing out
here why do I have
this I never listen to this [__] I'm
listen to this when my kids move out in
[__] 20 years but I can't do it
now I can't be out here in the garage
all of my [__] is in the [__]
garage
um which makes sense because if it
didn't it our house would be
weird you know
just the [__] I have on the [__]
walls just looking John bonom Bobby or
ACDC Dr J it's helicopters what am I
[__] 8 years old yes yes I
am
um anyway
so still have a slight [__]
headache I'm not going to lie to you
dude I was [__] C
Russian cigars I was doing one a day
which isn't good
but I was
[__]
crushing
coffee on bad days I would have like
three
cappuccinos on really bad days three
cappuccinos and a double espresso like I
know you guys are all going dude what
the [__] it's just like you know what it
is I don't there I don't have anything
else like I don't know what to do when
I'm sitting with other people I need
something to do and I started thinking
why do I need something to
do I have something to do go to bed or
just [__] sit there and drink of
water I think I was just like used to
drinking you know [__] bend in the
elbow you know so that became cigars and
it became like [__]
coffee all right you know what I'm going
to keep my [__] hands
down hands down here for I don't know
I'm going to go like 10 days see how
this works out and then maybe I'll go a
little bit
longer
um I don't know I will tell you I did
not appreciate that [__] headache
whatsoever that
information really let me know how
[__] uh cuz I definitely had people
like dude you're drinking another one if
I was doing that I couldn't go to sleep
it's like dude I'm a [__] Ginger I'm
weird I can drink a double espresso and
go to bed within an hour and sleep 8
hours and not even have weird dreams
Sugar's a different thing and I don't
like [__] weed
either that there's a thing right there
dude [__]
weed whatever it is now you know they
talk you know that kid was talking about
earlier what the [__] is in shampoo let
me ask you a question what the [__] is
in weed right now those stupid gummies
what are those crystals on it
sugar you putting sugar you know
something sugar is for [__] [__]
why are they going to make everything
taste good they want it to be addictive
is what it is but like
you know do you remember eating like pot
brownies when you were younger I mean
you tasted the [__] weed you were
like
godamn it's like you're eating a
shrub you [__] tasted it you're like
God I am eating [__]
marijuana I'm eating marijuana you know
eat a gummy it's like I don't know what
this is is this like [__] glue then
they put that little bit of those
crystals on it like I have no [__]
idea what that stuff is and then all
these different strand
like this one makes you creative this
one makes you [__] chill this one's
like let's get [__] up and hey we're
going to build a house on this one it's
just like weed used to just be weed so
like are they doing what they always do
are they playing God now are they
[__] with the DNA of the [__]
marijuana plant and at some point you
know when some Monsanto group is going
to own all the [__] seeds to weed and
if you [__] are growing it that's
what's going to be we in the Golden Age
of being a Weed Farmer as far as like
it's still you can be a private person
and do it I guarantee you pretty soon
some corporation's going to come in and
own all of it and it's going to [__]
suck and then you're going to have to go
to a farmer's market to get the organic
stuff man and then half of that [__] is
going to be the corporate [__] that they
W work their way in you seen that [__]
about those organic [__] uh products
and those
organic supermarkets you go in there
like most of them are already mainstream
Brands and all they do is they take a
couple of ingredients out and then
they're considered organic gee I
wondered how that happened they paid off
politicians they have people in the FDA
that used to work for them and they just
pass it through and you think that
you're getting away from their cancerous
horrible [__] and they're still feeding
it to you you will eat our stuff it's
[__]
unbelievable unbelievable how out of
control they are and then they they
spend more time trying to figure out
who's on steroids in baseball than they
do what these [__] [__] are Fe oh
I'm on a [__]
stump all right anyway this is the
podcast
everybody there are many like it but
this one is mine um this is the Monday
Morning podcast I hope you enjoyed it
um and uh I actually feel uh really good
feel really good man I feel [__] like
I slowed it down like I'm going to try
to remember this the next time it gets
out of control because that's just who I
am what am I never going to smoke
another cigar huh what am I never going
to go to Central America and do a hit
for the FBI like I've been doing for
these years no imagine if that I had
that whole other side of
me you know we're going to have you hide
in plain sight as a standup comedian you
know I don't think I want to do that no
just trust us just hang on we'll write
your jokes you just go out like the man
cheering candidate and you just say the
[__] jokes okay then once every 5 to
six years we're going to call you up and
there's going to be another beautiful
country in South America that we're
going to go down and [__] with and try
to take the natural resources you know
and then when they push back we'll claim
that they're you know anti-am whatever
we'll figure it out but we need you to
go down there's a guy down there that
actually cares about his own people and
we would like you to go down there and
eliminate him because we can't have that
um anyway all right that's uh that's the
podcast
everybody um go [__] your eles and I
will check in on you in a couple of
days